[Musique]
à leeds est d'accord pour inaugurer et
coup
cordon de cette terrasse c'est debout à
mes arguments l'avouer ça hier nathalie
vous voulez bien déclarer ouverte la
saison des dîners de 7 à vous alors je
déclare ouverte la saison des dîners de
7 à vous bravo et je coupe les jambes
étaient là pour ceux qui nous écoutent
on a reconstitué un bistrot ici dans le
plateau sur le plateau des déchets
vas-y vient on regarde petit jus
d'orange qui appuie franck a fait froid
parce que les séries puis deux heures et
croissants croissant qui saura ne sais
pas encore et attention à pauline c'est
le bruit qu'on rêve d'entendre depuis
des mois
les passes sont prêtent attention elle
est discrète elle est l'oeuvre des ça
cool mais ça coule en direct apolline
preuve que l'impatience est immense à
l'aller le couvert et déjà mis à
distance évidemment respectable 50%
la jauge juillet et forcément le gel
hydroalcoolique pour pour se désinfecter
parce qu alain ducardonnet nous disait
tout à l'heure il faut continuer à
respecter les gestes barrière écoutez ce
bruit de la petite cuillère en direct en
terrasse ce matin il est quoi 6h15 et
oui on est en train de boire un café en
terrasse à pauline qui l'eût cru même le
chef de l'état a été boire son petit
café en terrasse ce matin avec louis
voilà loin des caméras pas tout à fait
inconnu tôt quand même non c'était juste
à côté de l'elysée dans le viiie
arrondissement de paris
très bien
dites moi vous êtes content qu'on ait le
sourire les français sont contents karim
benzema revient en équipe de france tu
en as bien je vais vous dire les
sélections de villiers deschamps mais
par définition raison c'est lui qui
pilote il a bu deux cafés 2-2 expresso
les plus grands du monde on a compté le
nombre de fois où il porte la tasse à
ses lèvres
c'est vertigineux ça fait beaucoup pour
ces centres cage une de 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
gorgées d'une part centilitres ça fait
beaucoup
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances avec en a profité de cette
réouverture pour prendre un café voilà
devant quelques caméras dans le 6e
arrondissement de paris bruno le maire
tranquillement mais voilà petit moment
de liberté retrouvée collectif qui est
le fruit de nos efforts collectifs
ils ont payé ou pas et il mine pour bien
vite et qui monsieur mâcon a invité
geoffrey ou non même pas non ah ouais et
wc c'était une belle image franchement
cd président people cd président d'un
nouveau genre c'est pas des politiques
ont des parcours particulier veut dire
moi je n'ai raconté que ce que j'ai lu
ou entendu sur les journaux people
donc on a quand même affaire un des
lascars qui sont très très imbus
d'eux-mêmes très sûrs d'eux et surtout
qu'ils sont là pour l'intérêt que ça ça
leur amène et apporte la salle et vous
bonsoir c'est vraiment là ça va bonsoir
alors est ce confort alors qu'adrien
matin ont tous relevé le mas côté un
salon alors la règle c'est qu'on garde
le match jusqu'à ce qu'on soit la
boisson la 1er place verte si on dit ça
n'est pas brillé après il faut le
remettre pour payer une fois qu'on a
consommé vous avez vu le monde qui
enterra se voit
une nouvelle date a adhéré
oui
[Musique]
s'il y avait un meilleur souvenir c'est
quoi pour moi c'est celui-là c'est
aujourd'hui aux gens de voir ça si les
basques
y a pas deux mais il n'y a pas de ligne
a pas de bons souvenirs dans cette crise
je pense que je vis mon meilleur
souvenir de porte parole eh ben ça me
fait plaisir que vit avec moi
franchement c'est pour nous je vais
quand même je vais quand même bientôt
s'il vous plaît c'est pour moi j'avais
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le retour d'un plaisir simple
celui de lire le journal le matin en
buvant son café
beaucoup attendait cela depuis très
longtemps trop longtemps pour
quelques-uns qui n'ont pas attendu une
heure raisonnable pour commencer l'apéro
je vais profiter de cette belle journée
pour aller sur les terrasses consommer
des cafés et
que des cafés et du passé ce à partir du
luigi avec modération ah oui modération
modération merci à bernard montiel et
toute l'équipe de pour les bruitages
je travaille donc à la régulation du
samu j'ai fait un gâteau en rapport avec
mon métier donc attention au niveau de
l'estomac à ce point ça va être joli
joli comme les autres
rwasa aux mondieux soit à la situa avait
un super pouvoir se fera laquelle de
nick et le corps un navire russe
mélodique et cher le [ __ ] grave lui
dire tu rentres chez toi mec tu tousses
[Musique]
situe tout cela me touche énormément
quand tu vas faire caca sais comment
c'est trop dur trop bon bon bon parce
que parce que c'est du caca trop dur ah
oui c'est du caca dur d'accord oui ça
c'est un gros caca
bah oui tu sais toi aussi tu as fait
têtu c'était kaka comme ça quand section
azu'u ma première catastrophe
je suis pas sereine mais bon voilà c'est
vraiment sortir de ma zone de confort
mais en même temps je suis bien avec à
bout ça me fait du bien être avec lui
donc peu importe l'endroit en fait
passer le k k des chevals ces
catastrophes
c'est une catastrophe mais en même temps
je me sens bien j'ai bien besoin
besoin de se détendre un peu
chez son demi finale c'est bon ça
[Musique]